I was putting together this list of
movies I'm excited for in 2018 and it
was like a scroll I was like I have to
delete a bunch of those so I'm just
letting you guys know up front there are
a lot more that I'm not gonna get you in
here so just let me know what you're
excited for and we can talk about it out
of this live but first up I'm gonna kick
it off with action movies because I was
like the biggest Tomb Raider fan
especially the 2013 game that came out
and they are doing a movie actually
based off of that video games starting
Alicia vikander and it looks pretty much
shot-for-shot like the video game so I'm
extremely pumped for that unfortunately
video game movies are just across the
board basically a critical failure but
this is something that I'm just like
really holding home so yeah or like
please for the love of God um another
movie that is held by women we've got
our oceans 8 which is our all-female
oceans movie more of a crime comedy
instead of an action movie but that's
gonna bring together Rihanna Sandra
Bullock a planchette Anne Hathaway and
way more I don't know if you've heard of
any of these ladies they're gonna get
their big break yeah what is now my
favorite season of the year I don't know
what you've done to me and our
friendship cuz now I'm like really into
Halloween and fall um but we're getting
our return of Jamie Lee Curtis as Laurie
Strode in the final showdown between
Laurie and Michael Myers yes they're
getting rid of you know one of the other
Halloween movies I guess but not all of
them but some of them yep they're
getting rid of that one um so this is
said to be the final film in the
Halloween franchise at least for Jamie
Lee Curtis possibly I don't really
believe that I think they're gonna bring
that back but that's October 19th
moving on to comedy so I'm a big fan of
Talladega Nights
so brothers only thing with little arrow
and john c reilly and people hadn't
really been talking about this but
there's a holmes and watson movie coming
in november with dead with them i
actually have not heard about i have
enough is it all bringing these two guys
back together
i've heard
what about it so I I'm wondering how
stuck on the schedule that is but it
still looks promising yeah looks like a
moment this Getty stone looks promising
um and then on 4/20 haha Super Troopers
two of the highly anticipated corporal
to the 2002 movie the troopers are back
getting into more shenanigans right now
right now right now right now um but
that's not family-friendly you know it
is there's quite a few actually um call
me a hipster but Wes Anderson is one of
my favorite favorite filmmakers of all
time and we haven't got a movie from him
in four years since grand Budapest hotel
but he's back with Isle of Dogs and it's
kind of in the vein of like a fantastic
mr. Fox kind of stop-motion going on go
star-studded cast I am just so excited
so that had me at 23rd yeah
adorable I'm ready and it's literally
about an island of dogs I want to live
there and there's everything like a very
minor teaser of this but Pixar is
bringing in The Incredibles back with
Incredibles 2 this was like the most
minor teaser trailer and people lost
their minds
lost their minds so yeah be incredible
our back Jack Jack is back and he's got
powers and the family's figuring that
out um another movie that is not Pixar
of a lot of people think it is for some
reason is wreck-it Ralph so Ralph breaks
the Internet that's right is the sequel
and I gotta be honest I was not excited
about this movie initially but then I
went to d23 over the summer where they
showed a lot of preview footage and this
movie I've never laughed so hard at like
a kids movie in my entire life parents
are gonna be dragging their kids to you
because it's a Disney property so
they're incorporating all the Disney
Princesses are in it most of them at
least
and some Star Wars characters and they
you know Ralph etc they all interact
with them and it's so freakin funny were
you a fan of the first one yes I was I
wasn't super like when I was like cool
sequel that'll be nice you didn't need
to see I didn't II it
I'm telling you done it and now you're
like I don't like okay alright um so
here's the what is the sentence I say
every year you guys this is the year of
the super there are seven superhero
movies dropping in 2018 and I'm just
gonna list them off because if we get
into it's gonna be too much so we've got
Black Panther Avengers infinity war
Deadpool 2 ant-man on the wasp venom
x-men Dark Phoenix and Aquaman that's
not all the superhero movies that's at
least all the comic-book ones I'm sure
I'm missing a few superhero ones you
know what I mean but all those I've got
to say Black Panther is like my most
highly anticipated solo slash standalone
movie it looks amazing and I'm really in
love with chadwick boseman it might be
Jordan up there definitely watching this
yes yeah but that would bethe soul and
movies finally here cuz they were in I
didn't know we were getting an Aquaman
standalone yes and you know what I gotta
say I was like not excited about him and
then I watched Justice League and he is
like this bro II kind of dude but I
loved it I just love looking at Jason
Momoa
yeah I'm like ready for it I like that
we did have this conversation washer Oh
but Avengers infinity war is like the
Olympics of superhero movies not the
Super Bowl it's the Olympics um we're
bringing everyone together all the
Marvel characters for a big showdown I
don't know who's gonna make it out but
let's take a little bit of a look at the
straight line
put a smile on my face
slow motion drugs this doesn't look good
for someone at least yeah it's gonna be
real dark real fast make your
predictions now who do you think she's
gonna die we did not plan this we're
putting her on the spot
I I have this is like a wild prediction
like I have no grounds to even say this
I feel like they could maybe kill off
Thor and then do a solo Valkyrie movie
interesting it's like that's like a wild
thing that I'm just putting into my
University it's gonna be wrong
is this a spoiler if I talk about Thor
stuff so haven't seen Thor came out over
sorry okay closer he already lost his
eye and whose hammer I think he's been
through enough
it's true but you just kind of think of
a behind the scenes house just Chris
Hemsworth want to keep doing this you
know what I mean same with Robert Downey
jr. and Chris Evans like you're not
gonna be in it forever
I feel like they're nearing the end of
their way their journey is setting up
for new people so I feel like one of
those three is not gonna have the best
of luck I don't know it's gonna be I
just picked for like a roadie and
sweeper who knows
um so while not quite a superhero but a
hero nonetheless the last Jedi is here
like now but we only have to wait five
months I don't get our next Star Wars
movie because the Han Solo movies solo a
Star Wars story is coming um may 25th
and yeah this picture is the only one we
have because that's the only one they
put out so far but it is obviously
outdated because Phil Lord and Chris
Miller are no longer the directors
that's Ron Howard but hey we've got
Donna Glover in there as lambda which
I'm really excited to see and who knows
what that story will be probably the
Kessel run 40 parsecs they're 12
whatever um but the bummer about that is
that we don't get at other Star Wars
movie until episode 9 so my question is
why they typically do December releases
so why are they doing May I believe what
it was is they wanted to kind of get
back to the may release which was what
the original okay films were but then so
they wanted to do that with with Han
Solo and then they actually switched up
the trigger the directors for Episode
nine as well as John Colin Trevorrow and
now it's gonna be JJ Abrams again so
they kind of have to push it
back to December to give him a little
more time I love the December tradition
I hope they keep it but I like their
kind of touring with my prediction is
that eventually it'll be to a year and
they'll do like a may-december thing oh
but I think there are a little bit of
ways offering I think this number is
awesome because I mean you it's
something you share with your dad right
so it's nice like be together at the
holidays and like be able to share it
with your family if you grew up on it
it's a holiday thing for sure yeah also
it's nice to have that one really big
holiday movie to really look forward to
because May it's jam-packed with so many
other yes so always has a big season